[Music]
this trailer is rated R for Robocop
because that's how you make a [ __ ]
Robocop movie it's been more than 20
years since Robocop appeared on the big
screen and now he's back with a flip of
visor different origin a human hand and
a pg-13 rating screw that
instead revisit the original masterpiece
that is Robocop journey to a futuristic
Detroit that's become a bankrupt crime
ridden hellhole basically present-day
Detroit
it's a city crying out for a savior and
they'll get one in Robocop a blatant
Jesus metaphor who's killed gets
resurrected and walks on water but
instead of dying for our sins
this Jesus shoots rapists in the dick
meet his gum-chewing partner Lewis a
terrible cop who never waits for backup
runs like a girl and can't resist male
nudity mind a fire zip this bogs
together they'll take down old Detroit's
biggest bad guys Clarence Boddicker
a drug lord who's got a real way with
the ladies maybe you could omni consumer
products and evil corporation that does
everything except make consumer products
IDI 209 a heavily armed killing machine
who loses to a flight of stairs
and glass
[Music]
Robo suit up for the ultimate awesome
80s movie full of big hair cocaine goo
Goo's Cold War paranoia and a
no-nonsense black police captain so
return to a time when action movies were
made for adults but marketed to children
Robocop and evil easy to 16 face off
with rapid repeat cap hiring featuring
some of film's best one-liners that our
lives you're coming with me your move
creep hi that [ __ ] leave and the most
flat squibs ever
I guarantee you won't see that in the
remake starring Daft Punk Bruce Jenner
tough lady cop old eighties businessman
even older eighties businessman Jordan
Belfort that 70s drug lord Fox News and
Lindsay Lohan
[Music]
Robocop Robocop is the last movie that
needs a freakin remake what are they
gonna do next tie hard Oh No I've said
too much hey screen junkies for more
awesome stuff click here to subscribe I
am serious and don't call me Shirley I
am fire I am dead Pizza Delivery for ic
wiener has anyone really been far even
as decided to use even go want to do
look more like in a world where potatoes
rule the earth one carrot will rise